[Applaus]
Katar Austragungsort der Fußball-WM
auch ein paar Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer tragen im reichen Wüstenstaat
zum reibungslosen Ablauf des
umstrittenen Turniers bei einige von
ihnen leben schon lange hier
und eine Flugstunde entfernt Dubai
offener und schillernder als Katar ein
Paradies für fremde wenn man sich an die
Regeln hält wir begleiten fünf
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer die sich
auf das Abenteuer am Golf eingelassen
haben
worin liegt der Reiz was sind die
Herausforderungen des Alltags und fühlen
Sie sich trotz des kulturunterschieds
heimisch
es ist august in Doha der Hauptstadt
Katars
Chris Franzen muss noch einiges von
seiner To-Do-Liste streichen bevor er
sein Hotel eröffnen kann
bereits vor ein paar Monaten hat der
Zermatter für seine VIP-Gäste eine
exklusive Mitfahrgelegenheit bestellt
doch noch parkt sie im Showroom
3 Millionen
für 2,2%
für umgerechnet 800.000 Schweizer
Franken bekommt Chris die britische
Legende
was natürlich ganz schönes
in dem Fall
mindestens so legendär die Kühlerfigur
die spirit of ecstasy ein begehrtes
diebstahlobjekt sowas hatten sie wenn
man eine
stiletteile
the moment
[Musik]
in Katar gibt es zwei Jahreszeiten
Sommer und Winter dass die Fußball-WM im
November stattfindet hat einen Grund
in den Sommermonaten ist das Wüstenklima
so extrem dass man sich eigentlich nur
in klimatisierten Räumen aufhalten kann
auch Coralie kommt mit ihren Kindern oft
hierher weil es erträglich ist
im Sommer bleibt man eher drinnen weil
es sehr heiß ist die Luftfeuchtigkeit
ist zu hoch vor allem für die Kinder
selbst hier drinnen schwitze ich kaum
vorstellbar wie es gerade draußen wäre
machen wir normalerweise entweder
freitags oder samstags dann gehen wir
nach Hause die Kinder sind müde wir sind
müde wir schlafen danach alle ziemlich
gut
[Musik]
heute ist ausnahmsweise auch Zeit dabei
der zweijährige Abdul Rahman wächst in
einem anderen Katar auf als seine Eltern
als Coralie und Zeit Kinder waren
erstreckte sich hier noch die Wüste
ich finde es cool mein Sohn ist ein
bisschen zu klein für einige Spiele hier
in ein paar Jahren ist es sicher besser
Coralie hat sich mit ihrem Cousin
verbrennen zum Land verabredet wenn ist
auch in Doha aufgewachsen und hat ihre
Beziehung zu Zeit von Beginn an
miterlebt
seit ist wegen seines Motorradsports oft
in Europa
sozialisiert beide kennen die Kultur
ihres Partners gut
meine Frau sieht europäisch aus aber sie
ist es nicht sie ist eher international
mit katarischen Eigenschaften und
europäischen Eigenschaften um ehrlich zu
sein finde ich sie außergewöhnlich
ich bin genauso katari wie er europäisch
ist
das interessante es funktioniert
aber nicht immer wenn er beschließt
katari zu sein ist der katari wenn er
beschließt europäisch zu sein ist der
europäisch aber es funktioniert gut
gemeinsam durch ihre Höhen und Tiefen
und sie kommen immer als Gewinner heraus
sie unterstützen sich gegenseitig bei
allem was sie tun sei es bei Saids
Rennsport oder coralis Karriere sie
unterstützen die Ziele des anderen und
sie arbeiten als Paar an ihrer Beziehung
[Applaus]
schön
Doha durchlebt aktuell einen
gigantischen Wandel den die
nachbarmetropole Dubai längst hinter
sich hat nur im alten Stadtkern der
Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts am Hafen
entstand ist das Dubai von damals noch
spürbar und die Zeichen stehen weiter
auf Wachstum
Matteo Buffer ist mit Ehefrau Meghan
unterwegs zu einer neugebauten Siedlung
außerhalb des Zentrums die beiden wollen
eine Familie gründen dazu gehört Haus
und Garten
regelmäßig schauen Sie sich um was der
Immobilienmarkt so hergibt dieses kleine
Reihenhaus kostet umgerechnet 450.000
Franken
bei Dubai properties
es ist a brandnew Community brand new
house I West just Hand in over recently
the price of this one is one point 7
million
AIDA
im Moment leben Matteo und Meghan in
ihrem trendigen Apartment der Umzug in
eine solche Einfamilienhaussiedlung wäre
eine große Veränderung
jede Community hier die es gibt kommt
mit einem eigenen Pool mit eigenem Gym
mit Sportplätzen sowie Tennis Fußball
Basketball ist alles in der Community
inkludiert und das Konzept ist darauf
ausgelegt dass wenn die Leute hier leben
sind die Community eigentlich nicht mehr
verlassen müssen
wie so oft ein Knackpunkt die Größe
Matteo und Meghan versprechen sich vom
Hauskauf vor allem eines mehr Platz und
auch einen hübschen Garten
damit sie so viel draußen sein können
wie Sie möchten
natürlich wenn wir Kinder haben sie
brauchen draußen Platz um herumzulaufen
der Außenbereich sollte größer sein
[Musik]
großzügig und mit viel Wasser begrünt
ist der 119 Hektar große Dubai
Safaripark Andreas Vater ist aus der
Schweiz angereist es sind Ferien in
Dubai eine gute Gelegenheit um mit
Enkelin Sophie ein paar der 3000
Tierarten hier zu bewundern
[Musik]
beim gemacht
aber Ring zum Glück dürfen
die Außentemperatur beträgt um die 40
Grad das ist nicht nur für die
Zoobesuche anstrengend doch weil Dubai
wieder Kosten noch Mühen scheut findet
sich auch dafür eine Lösung eine
outdoor-klimaanlage für Mensch und Tier
das sind die Geräusche der Welt
sicher im Strom von der solarpfen
für Andreas Vater sind gemeinsame
Erlebnisse mit Sophie selten
[Musik]
doch der Pensionär macht das Beste draus
und kommt oft hierher
er war als Reiseleiter früher viel in
der Welt unterwegs und versteht wie
bereichernd diese Erfahrung für seine
Tochter und seine Enkelin ist
für Andrea ist es ein Abenteuer auf Zeit
Meghan und Matteo wollen länger bleiben
und suchen ihr Traumhaus
der Garten ist hübsch und größer als der
andere vorher
das zweite Objekt an diesem Tag scheint
etwas vielversprechender
geschützt zu sein man hat seinen
privaten Raum und es gibt einen kleinen
Rasen
ja es wäre schön mit einem kleinen Pool
und einer kleinen Schaukel das könnte
funktionieren
anders als der Neubau wurde dieses Haus
schon bewohnt die Küche ist 15 Jahre alt
[Musik]
ist ein guter Unternehmer aber
handwerklich nicht sehr talentiert
[Musik]
einen zusätzlichen Raum für die Nanny
wie es in vielen Familien hier üblich
ist braucht das Paar nicht
gesagt bin ich gegen eine Nanny für uns
Schweizer ist es unüblich ich bin ohne
Nanny aufgewachsen meine Mutter war
alleine mit drei Kindern und hat das
toll gemacht
also bleibt alles an Meghan hängen oder
wie genau hat sich der 31-Jährige die
Kinderbetreuung vorgestellt
ich würde gerne zu Hause bleiben und von
zu Hause arbeiten ich mache das ja schon
seit vielen Jahren außerdem koche ich
gerne ich glaube ich wäre ein guter
Vater
ob die beiden ihre Kinder in einem
solchen Community Haus aufziehen werden
hängt auch vom Erfolg seiner nächsten
business-investitionen ab
Investoren in diesem Preissegment und in
diesen Communities sehen die Häuser
natürlich alle gleich aus
aber wenn das Geschäft in Zukunft gut
läuft kann man auch nach etwas
Außergewöhnlichem schauen
zurück in Katar für die Familie von
Chris gibt es traurige Neuigkeiten
Rachel muss überraschend in ihrer Heimat
Australien reisen ihr Vater ist schwer
krank
wer sich für ein Leben als expert
entscheidet
opfert damit immer die Nähe zum
Elternhaus
eine Tatsache mit der man leben lernen
muss
[Musik]
gut
Noah greates
[Musik]
aber meistens
trotzdem stellt einen die Distanz bei
jedem tragischen Vorfall immer wieder
aufs Neue vor Entscheidungen und
manchmal bereut man sie dann im
Nachhinein
vor vier Jahren starb meine Oma und ich
habe es nicht zur Beerdigung geschafft
das war schlimm weil wir uns sehr nahe
standen aber meine Mutter sagte sie ist
schon gestorben und ihr habt euch
gesehen als sie noch gelebt hat darauf
kommt es an deswegen fahre ich jetzt bei
mein Vater noch lebt
ein Leben ständig an anderen Orten ist
auch eine Herausforderung für die beiden
Kinder Alex und Ashley doch für ihre
Eltern bedeutet das Nomaden da sein
Lebensglück
ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen an
einem Ort zu leben mein Sohn schon
diesen Sommer meinte er würde gerne in
der Schweiz leben aber ashley ist eher
wie wir
[Musik]
morgen früh trifft Rachel ihren Bruder
in Sydney über 12.000 km Luftlinie
liegen vor ihr
im Haus von Coralie herrscht
Aufbruchstimmung
[Musik]
haben Geld für ein eigenes Haus gespart
die Genehmigung ist erteilt doch noch
gibt es offene Punkte unter anderem die
Größe des Matjes dem offiziellen
Besuchsraum der in katarischen Häusern
für die Männer reserviert ist
seit ewigen Zeiten hat jedes Haus einen
Raum den wir matschless nennen die
meisten Häuser haben dafür einen extra
Gebäude wenn man herumfährt sieht man
sie neben den Wohnhäusern kleine Bauten
mit Lichtern und vielen Autos davor da
sitzen die Männer
Heilige Geist wenn du Freunde zum Lunch
einlädst kommen sie nicht ins Haus und
dann gehen in den matschlis das Haus hat
seine eigene Privatsphäre
dieses Haus hat auch zwei Eingänge
eine Tür ist hier die andere dort diesen
Bereich dahinter würde man als matschis
nutzen und dort ist das Haus und diese
Seite würde man zu machen
und dies ist die Rückseite
es ist ganz anders als die normalen
Häuser hier das gab Probleme als wir
wegen der Baugenehmigung zur Regierung
gegangen sind
eine Wand hat so kleine Vorsprünge es
ist an Design
vielleicht 20 Zentimeter
sie wollten es gerade aber nein gerade
hässlich ich möchte es genauso
ein Haus zu bauen ist eine Challenge für
jede Beziehung ein Haus in Katar zu
bauen bedeutet für Coralie zudem dass
die Schweiz ihre Feriendestination
bleiben wird
ideal wäre ich hätte einen Job wo ich
oder nein wenn ich aufhören könnte zu
arbeiten am ersten Tag der Ferien ab in
die Schweiz ins Haus meines Vaters für
den ganzen Sommer und erst am letzten
Tag zurück bevor die Schule wieder
anfängt
am nächsten Morgen in Doha Chris
erscheint immer zur selben Zeit am
Arbeitsplatz wie die meisten seiner
Angestellten
morning knapp 900 werden es bei der
Eröffnung in acht Wochen sein der
Stresspegel steigt aber Chris ist solche
Situationen gewohnt
[Musik]
sonnig was mir sehr wichtig ist ist dass
sie keine
zu mir ins Büro erkennen kann wenn das
Problem hängt man darf nicht vergessen
diesen zum ersten Mal weg von der
heimung und das natürlich schon es ist
Erlaubnis
einen dreistelligen Millionenbetrag
investiert der katarische Besitzer in
der Neubau damit bis im November alles
klappt heißt es jeden Tag üben üben üben
zu denken
wenn dünnes Zimmer
auf der anderen Seite
wichtig sind in der luxuslotterie
richtig schön Seesicht hoffe natürlich
schon das ist alles fertig wird aber ich
bin zu Jahr hier um Max sieht natürlich
schon dass das vorwärts geht und wir
organisiert dass sie sind
Organisation ist das wichtigste Wort für
einen Hotelmanager läuft das kleinste
Rad im Getriebe falsch Gerät der ganze
Betrieb ins Stocken
150 verschiedene
Rezept auf dem Menü nur für das einzige
Restaurants und da müssen natürlich
alles um Ihre Uhrzeit
sind und das wird so durchgearbeitet in
jedem Restaurant
in Dubai steht Andrea ebenfalls vor
einer Premiere
sie hat ihre Lizenz als Freelancerin
erhalten und empfängt ihre erste Kundin
Kerstin ist ebenfalls aus der Schweiz
[Musik]
Andrea könnte mit ihrer Lizenz auch
Hausbesuche machen doch weil Ferien sind
hat sie für Kerstin kurzerhand die Küche
zum Coiffeursalon umfunktion
ganz klares friseurstudierter hey ist
entweder
ich fühle mich schon entspannter
coiffeus aus Leidenschaft und
erfolgreiche Geschäftsfrau andrea hat
ihr Geschäft in Bern seit der Übernahme
in nur eineinhalb Jahren in die
schwarzen Zahlen geführt
kerstin hat sie hier kennengelernt
ich freue mich auf jeden Fall dass jetzt
die Lizenz hat und ich hoffentlich mich
andrea hat ihr Ziel erreicht sie kann
endlich wieder selbst Hand anlegen über
praktische Dinge wie eine Preisliste
oder ein Kreditkartenlesegerät hat sie
noch gar nicht nachgedacht
uns geht es überhaupt nicht um Geld oder
sondern wirklich um Mini inneren
und Gesellschaft
danke
Kerstin wird wiederkommen Dubai ist ein
gutes Pflaster um Business zu machen
[Musik]
Matteo hat mit nachhaltigen Start-ups
bereits einige erfolgstreffer gelandet
[Musik]
und er hat das nächste bereits im Visier
leider der Grund warum ich entschieden
habe in dieses neue Business zu
investieren ist eng mit diesem
wunderschönen Brief verbunden das Team
schreibt
Tod
wir wissen dass wir heute noch nicht
perfekt sind aber wir arbeiten hart und
dahin zu kommen einen handgeschriebenen
Brief habe ich seit langer Zeit nicht
mehr gesehen er hat mir ein positives
Gefühl vermittelt das war der erste
Schritt in Richtung dieses neuen
Abenteuers
diesmal geht es um schmutzige Wäsche
Matteo wurde auf das junge
Reinigungsunternehmen aufmerksam weil er
den Service selbst nutzte und für gut
befand
er kontaktierte den Besitzer war von
dessen Konzept überzeugt und investierte
mit zwei weiteren Partnern 100.000
US-Dollar
wie sie
ist
wirklich
45.000 neue geschäftslizenzen wurden
allein im ersten Halbjahr 2022 in Dubai
erteilt nicht überall wird schon so
fleißig gearbeitet wie hier
ich liebe solche Orte Startups sind
super es ist nicht bloß eine Idee
sondern etwas dass man riechen und
anfassen kann hier wird gearbeitet das
ist der Spirit in den ich gerne
investiere
gerade kommen die mittagsbestellungen
nicht einmal ein halbes Jahr ist die
Firmengründung her
für dieses
Jahres
Dubai mit
ich investiere auch in dieses
Unternehmen weil ich glaube dass die
Mitarbeiter hier gut behandelt werden
in diesem Branche gibt es immer noch
einige Firmen die ein bisschen unsauber
Wirtschaften
aber hier verbessern wir das Leben der
Arbeiter und tun was für die
Nachhaltigkeit
wir wollen auf Papiertüten umstellen und
ökologische organische Waschmittel
verwenden
möchte Matthäus Geld unter anderem in
PR-Maßnahmen investieren im Gegenzug
erhält Matteo dafür Anteile an seinem
Geschäft
ein Lied neue Ideen und neues Geld
helfen meinem Geschäft dabei zu wachsen
und da kommt der Investor ins Spiel aus
meiner Sicht ist es nicht so gut ein
ganzen kleinen Kuchen zu besitzen wenn
man noch ein Stück von einem sehr viel
größeren Kuchen haben kann
einer Wassermelone als 50% von einer
Weintraube
ganz genau er sagt es
[Musik]
in Katar bringt Chris sein Hotel und die
Crew weiter in Form
sein griechischer Chefkoch zeigt was man
sich unter einer fünf-sterne-küche
vorstellen muss
überrascht und hier ist neu ein paar
Sachen wo wirklich speziell sind das
wird der Rennen
genau
das Essen sollte nicht nur appetitlich
aussehen sondern auch mit Stil serviert
werden
eine Aufgabe um die sich Restaurantchef
Denise othmann persönlich kümmert gut
wie geht's denn Dennis alles okay
was machst du heute wird ein bisschen
Rollenspiel gespielt mal der Kellner ist
der Gast mal eine Hostess ist der
Parkcenter das machen wir jetzt bis wir
aufmachen jeden Tag und immer mal eine
unvorhergesehene Situation mit
reinschmeißen
vor einem Jahr hat Chris übernommen
wenig Zeit für eine solche Aufgabe
das ist klar
und man weiß nicht Kunstmaterial zur
Rechten zieht dann Katar oder nicht
weiter global logistics Challenge und so
weiter aber erst hätte geklappt und wir
Sie da und das wird schon
zwischen 280 für ein Standardzimmer und
18.000 Franken für eine Suite kostet die
Übernachtung hier doch der wahre Luxus
zeigt sich im drumherum
Erholung in der Kälte bei 40 Grad
Außentemperatur
Energiekrise gibt es hier nicht der
Mittlere Osten ist geprägt von
Gegensätzen Modernisierung und Tradition
Luxus und Armut alles eng nebeneinander
auch deswegen schauen viele kritisch auf
dieser Region Wien
Schweiz oder in Europa andauernd auf der
mittleren
negativ berichtet aber ich persönlich
sehe das absolut nicht so und die liegt
wo so reichend und das unterstützend
dieser die mal nach Katar und ich würde
eine Tiere hier schlecht
oder wenn
ich nicht kennt die moralisch
unterstützen
fakt ist dass Emirat ist wild
entschlossen aufzuholen und Geld ist
genügend vorhanden
2008 hat die Regierung eine nationale
Vision formuliert und begonnen die
komplette Infrastruktur zu erneuern
geschätzte 150 Milliarden Franken soll
Katar so investiert haben und natürlich
dient auch die WM der Image Pflege man
will dass die Welt sieht was sich
verändert hat
ein gewaltiger Wandel der sich ganz
konkret auf den Alltag der Menschen hier
auswirkt
mal einer also das wird eine großartige
Zeit diese WM
aber auch anstrengend für uns ich
arbeite bei der Polizei beim
Bombenkommando
natürlich werde ich rund um die Uhr
arbeiten sie wird rund um die Uhr
arbeiten ich hoffe der Rest hat
wenigstens Spaß
ich denke wenn sich der Hype um die WM
gelegt hat können wir schauen welche
Bereiche man jetzt vielleicht angeht
erst waren es die Baustellen jetzt kommt
die Hotellerie dran
gibt es noch reformpotenzial ja muss
alles jetzt sofort passieren nein wenn
man bedenkt was schon passiert ist und
wo wir jetzt sind das ist erstaunlich
von Beginn an war der Reform und
Modernisierungsprozess im Land vor allem
für die Einheimischen ein Balanceakt
es heißt Katar hätte eine Menge Geld für
die WM ausgegeben nein nicht für die WM
fürs Land
wir wollen seit Ewigkeiten eine U-Bahn
jetzt mit der WM kriegen wir die U-Bahn
danke
müssen wir uns weiter öffnen ich denke
nicht ich möchte nicht dass meine Kultur
verschwindet
und das machen sie hier ganz gut sie
versuchen wirklich die Kultur und Werte
zu bewahren
dieser Wille der Regierung die eigene
Kultur zu schützen zeigt sich auch in
der Stadtplanung
noch bis vor kurzem versorgte das Emirat
die Söhne der katarischen
stammesfamilien mit Bauland und
günstigen Krediten um die Familien
zusammen und wohl auch in ihrem
Heimatland zu halten
um einen schnellen Weiterverkauf zu
verhindern gehen Haus und Hof aber erst
nach 35 Jahren in den Besitz der
Bewohner über
dies ist das Stück Land das die
Regierung meinen Brüdern und mehr
zugeteilt hat
dort lebt man ältester Bruder erste
einzige der sein Haus schon gebaut hat
das hier gehört meinem zweitältesten
Bruder
dann kommt mein Land und dann das meines
vierten Bruders vier Brüder
dies ist das neue als Viertel
mein Vater lebt in dem alten Viertel
aber da war kein Land mehr dass man den
Kindern geben könnte
daher gibt es dieses neue Viertel hier
mein Land ist das hier gleich hinter dem
Haus
1150 Quadratmeter ja und ja jetzt da die
Pläne endlich fertig sind will ich so
bald wie möglich anfangen zu bauen
die Zukunft von Zeit und corallee
scheint gesichert die Katar seinen
eingeschlagenen Weg über die WM hinaus
weiterverfolgen wird darauf darf man
gespannt sein
die 3 Millionen Metropole Dubai wird
sich bei aller Tradition auch zukünftig
offen gegenüber partyfreudigen Touristen
und innovativen Start-ups zeigen
in einer Hotelbar in der City gönnen
sich Matteo unser neuer Geschäftspartner
savan einen Feierabend drink
Megan ist bei allen wichtigen
Entscheidungen dabei
die
spielt eine wichtige Rolle seit Meghan
meine Entscheidungen absegnet ich nenne
es das Megan Siegel lagen wir immer
richtig
es gab eine Situation das spürte ich so
ein Bauchgefühl ich sagte zu Matteo er
sei drauf und dran einen Fehler zu
machen er hat nicht auf mich gehört aber
am Ende stimmte mein Gefühl
ja das war in der Tat ziemlich schlimm
in dem Fall haben wir Geld verloren
eventually es wäre richtig gewesen auf
ihren Instinkt zu hören seitdem ich das
tue haben wir Erfolg
[Musik]
ich habe es ja auch mit savan bekannt
gemacht
sie spielt eine große Rolle im
Entscheidungsprozess und ich vertraue
jetzt zu 100% auf ihr Bauchgefühl
Lernprozess mal gewinnt man mal verliert
man
vergehen
in business
[Musik]
abendliche Idylle auch im Garten von
Andrea als sie 2019 Remo nach Dubai
begleitete erfüllte sich für den
Ingenieur ein großer Traum Andreas
selbst brauchte das klassische
eingewöhnungsjahr
[Musik]
heute ist die Familie nicht nur enger
zusammengewachsen sondern auch heimisch
geworden hier
Arme viel Zuschauer
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Remus Arbeitsvertrag war ursprünglich
auf drei Jahre befristet um ein Jahr
hatte ihn bereits verlängert
den Gedanken dass er die Zelte bald
wieder abbrechen muss verdrängt er
meistens erfolgreich
im Auto
wenn man diskutiert
neues
[Applaus]
bisher war es immer Andrea die eher
wieder zurück in die Heimat wollte damit
Tochter Sophie auch noch ein paar Jahre
ihrer Kindheit in der Schweiz verbringen
und sie ihren Coiffeur Laden in Bern vor
Ort weiterführen kann
[Musik]
doch das Schicksal hat eine Überraschung
parat
es gibt was zu feiern
wir trinken
erfreuliche Erfahrungen
und jetzt wollen wir natürlich die
Neuigkeiten fahren
[Musik]
andrea hat die angenehmen Seiten ihres
expert-lebens mit einer Nanny schätzen
gelernt das setzt Remo mit seinem
befristeten Arbeitsvertrag ein wenig
unter Druck ja
unbedingt in Dubai lieber und nach mir
also
ja also
[Gelächter]
und egal wohin es die Familie verschlägt
das nächste Abenteuer kommt bestimmt
[Musik]